Narrator:
THIS IS THE SHARK TANK,
WHERE ENTREPRENEURS
SEEK AN INVESTMENT
TO START, GROW, OR SAVE
THEIR BUSINESSES.
WE SELL PRODUCE WITH PURPOSE.
All:
WELCOME TO THE FUTURE OF FRESH!
Narrator: IF THE SHARKS HEAR
A GREAT IDEA...
IT WORKS!
BOOM!
Narrator: ...THEY'LL INVEST
THEIR OWN MONEY...
I WANT 50%.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
HILARIOUS.
...AND FIGHT EACH OTHER
FOR A DEAL.
I CAN HELP YOU RUN
THIS BUSINESS.
I CAN HELP YOU SCALE IT.
THANK GOODNESS I'M HERE.
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
Narrator: THE ENTREPRENEURS
MUST GET THE FULL AMOUNT
THEY'RE ASKING FOR,
OR THEY'LL WALK AWAY
WITH NOTHING.
I HAVE A REALLY GREAT MIND
FOR BUSINESS.
I DON'T THINK SO.
I'LL BE HONEST --
I WANTED TO DO FIVE TIMES
THAT VALUATION.
OH!
DO YOU SEE A PROBLEM IN THAT?
I'M TRYING TO BE KIND BEFORE
I ABSOLUTELY EVISCERATE YOU.
Narrator:
WHO ARE THE SHARKS?
THEY'RE SELF-MADE
BUSINESS EXPERTS WORTH BILLIONS.
KEVIN O'LEARY IS
A SHREWD VENTURE CAPITALIST
WHO MADE HIS FORTUNE
SELLING A CHILDREN'S
EDUCATIONAL COMPANY
FOR OVER $4 BILLION.
BARBARA CORCORAN WENT FROM
WAITING TABLES IN MANHATTAN
TO BUILDING THE CITY'S PREMIER
$2-BILLION REAL-ESTATE EMPIRE.
ROBERT HERJAVEC, SON OF
AN IMMIGRANT FACTORY WORKER,
FOUNDED ONE OF
THE WORLD'S PREEMINENT
CYBER-SECURITY FIRMS.
LORI GREINER, THE QUEEN OF QVC,
HOLDS OVER 100 PATENTS
AND HAS LAUNCHED
OVER 400 PRODUCTS,
GROSSING OVER A HALF A BILLION
DOLLARS IN SALES.
AND MARK CUBAN,
ESTEEMED BILLIONAIRE TECH MOGUL
AND THE OUTSPOKEN OWNER
OF THE DALLAS MAVERICKS.
FIRST INTO THE TANK IS
A FRESHENER WITH DUAL USES.
♪♪
HEY, SHARKS.
MY NAME IS TONY GAUTHIER.
I AM SCOTT HOAG.
AND I'M WESLEY OSAZE.
AND TOGETHER,
WE ARE THE OWNERS OF...
SPRETZ!
THE ONE SPRAY THAT IS...
TOO FRESH!
AND WE'RE SEEKING
A $100,000 INVESTMENT
FOR A 20% STAKE
IN OUR COMPANY.
SHARKS, IT ALL STARTED
WHEN I WAS HOSTING AN EVENT,
AND I SMELLED LIKE SMOKE.
NOW, I DIDN'T HAVE ANY MINTS,
CANDIES, LOTIONS, COLOGNES,
NOTHING. ALL I HAD
WAS A PIECE OF GUM.
OKAY, TONE, GUM DOESN'T REMOVE
ODORS FROM YOUR HANDS.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT DOESN'T.
NOW, I'M A LITTLE EMBARRASSED
TO ADMIT THIS,
BUT I STARTED CHEWING
THAT PIECE OF GUM
AND THEN I SPIT IT IN MY HANDS
AND STARTED ROLLING IT --
WHOA! WHOA! WHOA!
THAT'S NASTY.
THAT'S NOT SEXY,
RIGHT, SHARKS?
MNH-MNH. MNH-MNH.
BUT THAT'S WHEN
THE LIGHT BULB WENT OFF.
I THOUGHT TO MYSELF, "NOW,
WHAT IF THERE WAS ONE PRODUCT
THAT COULD REMOVE
THE SMELL OF ODORS
FROM BOTH YOUR BREATH
AND YOUR HANDS?"
BOOM!
AND THAT'S WHEN SPRETZ
WAS CONCEIVED.
SPRETZ IS THE FIRST ALL-NATURAL,
TWO-IN-ONE SPRAY PRODUCT
THAT DELIVERS A POWERFUL MIST
OF FRESHNESS
TO BOTH YOUR BREATH
AND YOUR HANDS.
JUST HAD SOME GARLIC FRIES
AT THE GAME?
SPRETZ!
YOU GOT A HOT DATE?
YOU CAN'T SMELL LIKE STINK.
SPRETZ!
SO, ALL IT TAKES IS A COUPLE
SPRAYS OF SPRITS
TO RESTORE YOUR CONFIDENCE
AND SECURITY.
All:
WELCOME TO THE FUTURE OF FRESH.
SO NOW WE'RE GONNA PASS OUT
A FEW SAMPLES.
THE FLAGSHIP FLAVORS --
CINNA-MINT AND PEPPERMINT.
Cuban: WOW!
Herjavec: BOOM!
THAT WAS GREAT, GUYS.
NICE JOB.
I JUST WANT TO KNOW HOW MANY
HOURS YOU GUYS WORKED ON THAT.
Hoag: THANK YOU.
Gauthier: JUST ONE.
YOU CAN SPRAY IT IN YOUR MOUTH,
AND YOU CAN SPRAY IT
ON YOUR HANDS.
RUB IT AROUND GENEROUSLY.
OOH, STRONG.
AND IT'S A POWERFUL MINT,
ROBERT.
SO THAT'S WHY IT
SMELLS STRONG.
YEAH, THAT'S POWERFUL.
OH, HELLO.
Greiner: ONE SPRITZ?
Osaze: IT SHOULD
WAKE YOU RIGHT UP.
I LIKE IT.
YOU CAN SPRAY IT
ON YOUR HANDS.
I HAVE A QUESTION.
YEAH, SURE.
SO, THIS IS NOT
A HAND SANITIZER.
Hoag: NO, MA'AM.
IT'S NOT A HAND SANITIZER.
IT IS IF YOUR HANDS
ARE STINKY?
YES. EXACTLY.
IT'S MORE OF A CONVENIENT WAY
TO FRESHEN UP WHILE ON THE GO.
HOW WOULD I KNOW,
IN THAT PACKAGING,
THAT IT ALSO CAN BE USED
ON MY HANDS?
SO, WITH --
YOU THREE GUYS
AREN'T GONNA BE DOING
HIP-HOP ROUTINES
IN EVERY STORE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
Osaze: SO, THIS IS THE FIRST
ITERATION OF THE PACKAGING.
THE SECOND ITERATION,
WE DO HAVE TO SHOW
THAT YOU CAN USE IT BOTH
ON YOUR BREATH AND HANDS.
YOU'RE GONNA CHANGE
YOUR LABEL?
YEAH.
YOU PUT IT ON THERE?
SO, WAIT, WAIT.
ARE YOU GUYS SELLING --
ARE YOU GUYS SELLING THIS
ANYWHERE AT ALL?
SO, PRE-CONCEPT -- WE'VE BEEN,
LIKE, DOING OUR TEST MARKET.
WE'VE SOLD CLOSE TO
1,000 UNITS ALREADY.
♪♪
THIS IS BEFORE --
AT WHAT PRICE, TONY?
AT $3.95.
LET'S JUST TAKE A SNAPSHOT
OF SALES SO FAR.
YOU'VE SOLD 1,000 UNITS?
MM-HMM.
YEAH.
SO, HOW MANY DOLLARS IS THAT?
$35,000-- $3,500.
$3,500?
YEAH.
IN JUST THE LAST 60 DAYS.
AND YOU'VE PUT IT --
PRE-LAUNCH,
WITHOUT ANY MARKETING
OR PROMOTION WHATSOEVER.
WHEN DID YOU START, THOUGH?
WHAT MONTH?
AND THAT WAS ON
YOUR WEBSITE, THEN?
-TWO MONTHS AGO.
ONLY TWO MONTHS AGO?
60 DAYS AGO. WE'VE ALREADY
SOLD CLOSE TO 1,000 UNITS
AND ALREADY HAVE
PURCHASE ORDERS
FROM SOME STORES
AND ALSO A MAJOR HOTEL.
HOW DID YOU SELL
THE FIRST 1,000 UNITS?
THAT'S IMPORTANT.
FACE-TO-FACE.
HAND-TO-HAND. FACE-TO-FACE.
WORD OF MOUTH.
HAND-TO-HAND.
COMING UP TO PEOPLE.
YOU WERE JUST
STANDING ON THE STREET?
I HAVE AN EXPERIMENT
FOR YOU.
CAN YOU PICK UP THE GARLIC
THAT'S ON THAT PLATE?
YEAH.
CAN YOU RUB IT AROUND
IN YOUR HAND?
THEN I WANT TO SMELL
YOUR HAND.
OKAY.
Hoag: SMELL TEST.
THEN I WANT TO SMELL IT
AFTER IT SPRITZ IT.
Osaze: [ LAUGHS ]
Herjavec: WOW!
OKAY.
SMELLS GARLICKY. KEVIN?
O'Leary: YEAH.
A LITTLE. IT SMELLS A LITTLE.
NOT A LOT.
NOW HIT IT.
BUT I'LL GIVE YOU --
I'LL GIVE YOU --
HIT IT WITH THE...
OKAY.
PUT SOME CHEESE ON THERE
WHILE YOU'RE AT IT. COME ON.
[ LAUGHTER ]
ALL RIGHT, YOU'RE GONNA
COME BACK IN A FEW MINUTES.
I WANT TO SMELL IT AGAIN.
OKAY.
O'Leary: I ALWAYS LIKE
TO BE AN OPTIMIST.
THAT'S WHY THEY CALL ME
MR. WONDERFUL.
LET'S ASSUME IT'S GREAT.
OKAY.
I'VE GIVEN YOU $100,000.
I SAY, "OKAY, GUYS,
LET'S GET SOME DISTRIBUTION."
RIGHT.
SO THIS THING HAS TO FIND ITS
WAY ONTO EVERY SHELF IN AMERICA.
HOW'S THAT GONNA WORK?
ABSOLUTELY. YES.
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE
SEEKING YOUR HELP.
OH, RIGHT.
Cuban: BUT IT'S NOT JUST
GETTING ON THE SHELF
IS NOT ALWAYS
THE HARDEST PART.
RIGHT.
COMING OFF THE SHELF
INTO SOMEONE'S POCKET
AND TAKING THEIR $4
IS THE HARD PART.
RIGHT.
AND I CAN JUST TELL YOU GUYS
MY NATURAL INCLINATION WAS,
"WAIT, THAT -- THAT
DOESN'T WORK FOR ME," RIGHT?
IN MY MOUTH AND ON MY HANDS.
SO IT'S A DISCONNECT.
I DON'T IMMEDIATELY THINK,
"OH, YEAH, MY BREATH STINKS.
MY HANDS STINK.
LET'S SPRAY AWAY," YOU KNOW?
WE'VE SAW THAT
IN OUR TEST MARKET,
A LOT OF PEOPLE HAVE MULTIPLE
ITEMS IN THEIR POCKET.
THEY HAVE THE GUM, THE LOTIONS,
THE SANITIZERS.
YOU'RE REDUCING THE NEED
TO BUY MULTIPLE ITEMS.
BUT YOU -- OKAY,
I GET THAT, RIGHT?
BUT THEN YOU HAVE TO
EDUCATE PEOPLE.
SO THAT'S THE HARD PART.
THAT'S THE PART
I'M SCARED ABOUT.
NOW YOU GUYS HAVE GOT TO
SPEND MILLIONS OF DOLLARS,
OR AT LEAST $1 MILLION
TO MARKET IT.
$100,000
IS NOWHERE NEAR ENOUGH
FOR YOU TO DO
WHAT YOU WANT TO DO.
I WISH YOU GUYS THE BEST.
I DON'T SEE IT WORKING.
SO FOR THOSE REASONS,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, MARK.
THAT RETAIL SPACE THAT
YOU GUYS ARE TALKING ABOUT --
THAT IS THE MOST EXPENSIVE
PER LINEAR FOOT
IN THE ENTIRE STORE.
YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT'S A NEW PRODUCT.
IT'S NEVER REALLY
BEEN DONE BEFORE.
WELL, IT'S ALSO A NEW CATEGORY.
IT'S A NEW CATEGORY.
RIGHT.
BUT OUR DRIVE,
OUR MOTIVATION,
OUR REASONS WHY --
YOU KNOW,
I LOST MY MOTHER EXACTLY
THREE YEARS AGO TO THIS DAY.
SORRY.
TO THIS DAY. YOU'RE RIGHT.
IT IS A NEW PRODUCT,
BUT ALL OF YOU GUYS
ARE UP HERE FOR A REASON --
'CAUSE YOU TOOK A CHANCE.
YOU TOOK AN OPPORTUNITY.
YOU TOOK A RISK.
[ Voice breaking ]
I OWE IT TO MY MOTHER,
I OWE IT TO THESE GUYS, AND I
OWE IT TO MY FAMILY AND MYSELF.
WE GOT TO DO IT,
AND THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
WE DON'T HAVE ALL THE ANSWERS.
BUT YOU GUYS DO.
TONY, IT'S GREAT PASSION,
BUT WE HAVE TO DEAL WITH
THE ECONOMIC REALITY.
THAT'S TRUE.
IT'S --
$100,000'S NOT ENOUGH.
YOU KNOW, I GO HOME.
I VISIT MY MONEY.
"DADDY'S HOME!"
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THEN I SAY, "GUYS,
I'M GONNA SEND A MILLION OF YOU
OUT TO SPRETZ."
"DADDY, PLEASE, NO!
NO, DADDY!
I DON'T WANT TO GO TO SPRETZ!
IT'S TOO RISKY!"
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND THAT'S WHAT I'M WORRIED
ABOUT. I REALLY AM.
I'M OUT. I'M OUT.
I'M OUT.
SO WE HAVE NOTICED -- ALL RIGHT,
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
WE APPRECIATE IT.
I SEE YOUR POINT.
I JUST -- NO WAY.
OKAY.
I DON'T THINK IT'S GONNA TAKE
$1 MILLION TO DRIVE THIS BRAND.
I THINK IF YOU SPEND $250,000,
YOU'RE GONNA BE ABLE TO DO IT,
IF YOU SPEND
YOUR MONEY WISELY.
RIGHT.
ABSOLUTELY.
O'Leary: THAT'S VERY GENEROUS
OF YOU, BARBARA.
ARE YOU GONNA GIVE THEM
$250,000?
I DIDN'T SAY THAT YET.
OH.
RIGHT?
I DIDN'T SAY THAT.
I DO AGREE WITH YOU, TONY,
ABOUT YOUR CONVICTION.
WE ALL FELT IT HERE.
AND I AGREE WITH
ALL OF YOUR HUSTLE.
YOUR ROUTINE IS POWERFUL.
I THINK YOU'RE WASTING IT
ON THIS TINY, LITTLE PRODUCT.
ON THIS PRODUCT
YOU'RE PITCHING, I AM OUT.
WAIT, WAIT,
BEFORE YOU SAY THAT --
OHH!
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THANK YOU.
LOOK, I LOVE THE HUSTLE,
BUT HUSTLE IS JUST
PAR FOR THE COURSE.
YOU CAN'T BUILD A BUSINESS
UNLESS YOU GOT THE HUSTLE.
ABSOLUTELY.
NOT GONNA WORK.
I'M NOT SURE THIS IS
THE RIGHT VEHICLE.
OKAY.
YOU GUYS ARE GREAT,
BUT I'M NOT SEEING THIS.
I'M OUT.
OKAY. THANK YOU.
BUT LORI'S STILL LEFT.
TONY, COME HERE.
LET ME SMELL YOUR HAND AGAIN.
[ LAUGHTER ]
AND SHE'S SMELLING YOU.
THAT'S A GOOD SIGN.
HEY, THE GARLIC IS GONE.
IT WORKS!
COME ON, LORI.
LISTEN, GUYS, I WOULD INVEST
IN YOU. YOU'RE AMAZING.
THE PROBLEM IS DO PEOPLE
REALLY HAVE A NEED
TO FRESHEN THEIR BREATH
AND THEIR HANDS?
I DON'T THINK THAT SMELLY HANDS
IS A HUGE PROBLEM
BECAUSE I THINK A LOT OF PEOPLE
JUST WASH THEIR HANDS
OR THEY USE HAND SANITIZER.
IT'S NOT THE RIGHT PRODUCT
FOR ME.
I'M OUT. IT DOES WORK.
BUT I THINK THAT,
GET OUT THERE, GRIND.
THERE ARE MORE GREAT IDEAS
TO COME.
OKAY.
THANKS, YOU GUYS, SO MUCH.
THANKS, GUYS.
ALL SHARKS ARE OUT.
Osaze: THANK YOU.
Cuban: GOOD LUCK, GUYS.
GOOD LUCK.
ALL RIGHT.
Osaze:
NOT GETTING A DEAL TODAY
JUST MEANS WE'RE GONNA HAVE TO
GO BACK TO THE DRAWING BOARD.
Gauthier: YEAH. BUT DEFINITELY
APPRECIATE THE FEEDBACK.
AND THEY SAID IT WORKS.
ABSOLUTELY.
YEAH.
THEY SAID IT WORKS.
♪♪
MY NAME IS EVAN LUTZ.
I'M 23 YEARS OLD.
AND I LIVE IN
BALTIMORE, MARYLAND.
MY ENTIRE LIFE, I'VE WANTED
TO BECOME AN ENTREPRENEUR,
AND GROWING UP IN BALTIMORE,
I SAW WAY TOO MUCH POVERTY
AND HUNGER.
AND I KNEW I WANTED TO START
A BUSINESS THAT MADE
A POSITIVE IMPACT
IN PEOPLE'S LIVES.
SO, WHAT KINDS OF PRODUCE
DO YOU GROW HERE?
I WAS SHOCKED WHEN I FOUND OUT
HOW MUCH FOOD GETS WASTED
IN THIS COUNTRY.
OVER 6 BILLION POUNDS OF PRODUCE
GETS THROWN AWAY
EVERY SINGLE YEAR.
A LARGE PORTION OF THAT WASTE
COMES FROM SPOILAGE ON FARMS.
AT THE END OF THE DAY,
IT'S TOUGH FOR FARMERS TO SELL
EVERY SINGLE PIECE
OF PRODUCE THEY GROW.
ALL THAT FOOD WASTE ENDS UP
IN LANDFILLS,
WHERE IT EMITS METHANE GAS,
WHICH IS A HUGE CONTRIBUTOR
TO GLOBAL WARMING.
HERE'S ONE.
I'VE MADE IT MY MISSION
TO HELP SOLVE THESE PROBLEMS
AND REDEFINE WASTE.
MY COMPANY PROVIDES THE MOST
AFFORDABLE AND CONVENIENT WAY
FOR CONSUMERS TO EAT HEALTHY AND
GIVE BACK TO THEIR COMMUNITY.
AND OUR CUSTOMERS
ARE EATING IT UP.
WE GOT GOOD STUFF.
I'VE POURED MY HEART, MY SOUL,
MY ENTIRE LIFE SAVINGS
INTO THIS BUSINESS.
WITHOUT AN INVESTMENT
FROM THE SHARKS,
OUR COMPANY MIGHT NOT BE ABLE
TO OFFER THE SOLUTION
THAT THIS COUNTRY
SO DESPERATELY NEEDS.
♪♪
HELLO, SHARKS.
MY NAME'S EVAN LUTZ.
I'M FROM BALTIMORE, MARYLAND.
I'M THE C.E.O. AND CO-FOUNDER
OF HUNGRY HARVEST.
AND I'M SEEKING $50,000
IN EXCHANGE
FOR 5% EQUITY IN MY COMPANY.
WHEN YOU'RE WALKING DOWN
THE GROCERY-STORE AISLE,
AND YOU SEE ALL THE APPLES
LINED UP ALL SHINY,
PERFECT, SAME SIZE, SAME COLOR,
SAME SHAPE, YOU MIGHT WONDER,
"HOW ON EARTH DO THEY GROW
THE SAME EXACT WAY?"
WELL, THE FACT IS THEY DIDN'T.
UNFORTUNATELY, THE FRUITS
AND VEGETABLES THAT DON'T MEET
THAT SUPERFICIAL CRITERIA
OFTENTIMES WIND UP
IN A LANDFILL.
6 BILLION POUNDS OF PRODUCE
GET THROWN AWAY
EVERY SINGLE YEAR
IN THE UNITED STATES.
50 MILLION AMERICANS,
ONE-SIXTH OF OUR COUNTRY
DON'T KNOW WHERE
THEIR NEXT MEAL IS COMING FROM.
AT HUNGRY HARVEST, WE USE
ONE PROBLEM TO SOLVE THE OTHER.
WE PURCHASE SURPLUS PRODUCE
FROM LOCAL FARMS AND WHOLESALERS
THAT NORMALLY GET THROWN AWAY,
NOT BECAUSE IT'S BAD OR ROTTEN,
BUT JUST BECAUSE IT'S UGLY.
FOR EXAMPLE, THESE BANANAS
AND THESE SWEET POTATOES --
WE DON'T DISCRIMINATE.
WE ASSEMBLE IT INTO VARIETY BAGS
AND DELIVER IT TO
OUR CUSTOMERS' DOORS
FOR A WEEKLY SUBSCRIPTION MODEL.
FOR EVERY BAG WE DELIVER
TO ONE OF OUR CUSTOMERS,
WE DONATE A HEALTHY MEAL
TO SOMEONE IN NEED.
WHEN OUR CUSTOMERS RECEIVE
THEIR DELIVERIES ON SUNDAYS,
THEY FEEL EXCITED 'CAUSE
NOT ONLY ARE THEY SAVING TIME,
SAVING MONEY,
AND EATING HEALTHY,
BUT THEY'RE HELPING REDUCE FOOD
WASTE, FEED HUNGRY FAMILIES,
SUPPORT LOCAL FARMERS,
AND CREATE JOBS FOR THOSE
GETTING BACK ON THEIR FEET.
HELP US FIGHT FOOD WASTE
AND HUNGER IN AMERICA.
WE'RE HUNGRY HARVEST.
WE SELL PRODUCE WITH PURPOSE.
SHARKS, WHO'S HUNGRY?
OF COURSE, I HAVE SOME SAMPLES,
SO I'LL PASS OUT SOME.
HERE YOU GO.
AND THIS IS OUR FULL SHARE.
SO THIS IS OUR $25 OPTION.
THANK YOU.
THESE LOOK LIKE THE ONES
I TRIED TO GROW.
IF YOU'RE A CUSTOMER...
YEAH.
...WHAT DO YOU PAY,
AND HOW DOES
THE SERVICE WORK?
WE HAVE THREE SIZE OPTIONS.
THE MINI IS $15 PER WEEK.
THAT'S ALL-INCLUSIVE CHARGE.
THE FULL IS $25.
AND THE SUPER IS $35.
SO EACH BAG INCLUDES
ONE TO TWO LEAFY GREENS,
THREE TO FIVE DIFFERENT TYPES
OF VEGETABLES,
TWO TO FOUR DIFFERENT TYPES OF
FRUIT, AND AN HERB OR FLAVORING.
O'Leary: IT'S JUST AS FRESH,
EXCEPT IT'S REJECTED
BECAUSE OF ITS VISUAL...
VISUAL. SO IT GOES TO WASTE
FOR TWO MAIN REASONS --
ONE, FOR COSMETIC
IMPERFECTIONS...
YEAH.
...AND, TWO, FOR LOGISTICAL
INEFFICIENCIES.
IT'S VERY TOUGH FOR FARMERS
TO GROW THE EXACT AMOUNT
OF PRODUCE THAT THEY'RE
CONTRACTED TO GROW.
ARE YOU BUYING IT DIRECTLY
FROM THE FARMER, THEN?
SO, WE HAVE A NETWORK
OF SUPPLIERS,
WHICH INCLUDES BOTH FARM
AND WHOLESALERS.
THE COOL PART ABOUT IT IS
WE KNOW EXACTLY
HOW MUCH PRODUCE TO ORDER
EACH WEEK.
WE HAVE NO INVENTORY RISK.
'CAUSE YOU ONLY ORDER BASED ON
SUBSCRIPTIONS YOU HAVE.
EXACTLY.
MM!
SO TELL US ABOUT
THE ACTUAL BUSINESS.
IN OUR FIRST SIX MONTHS
OF BUSINESS,
WE DID $37,000 IN SALES.
IN OUR LAST SIX MONTHS,
WE'VE DONE $104,000 IN SALES.
GOOD FOR YOU.
SO, THANK YOU.
RIGHT NOW WE'RE ACTUALLY
NOT PROFITABLE.
WE'VE HAD A NET LOSS
OF ABOUT $20,000.
ARE YOU PAYING YOURSELF
ANYTHING?
I'M NOT PAYING MYSELF QUITE YET.
EVAN, CAN YOU EQUATE
THOSE REVENUE NUMBERS
TO THE AMOUNT
OF CUSTOMERS?
RIGHT NOW WE HAVE JUST OVER
500 ACTIVE CUSTOMERS.
AND THAT MAKES A DIFFERENCE.
WE HAVE A REALLY UNIQUE
VALUE PROPOSITION.
THIS IS SAVING THEM TIME FROM
NOT GOING TO THE GROCERY STORE.
THIS IS SAVING THEM MONEY.
AND WE ALLOW THEM TO GIVE BACK
TO THE COMMUNITY SEAMLESSLY
JUST BY SIGNING UP.
CAN YOU EXPLAIN
MORE ABOUT THAT?
HOW? HOW DO
THEY DO THAT?
'CAUSE I DON'T THINK
WE UNDERSTAND
THE CHARITABLE COMPONENT OF IT.
Cuban: BECAUSE FOOD'S
NOT BEING WASTED.
RIGHT, SO, ON OUR BACK END,
WE'RE HELPING REDUCE FOOD WASTE
'CAUSE ALL THIS WOULD
NORMALLY GO TO WASTE.
WE'RE FEEDING HUNGRY FAMILIES
'CAUSE WE DONATE
1.2 POUNDS OF PRODUCE
FOR EVERY BAG WE DELIVER.
YOU DO? OKAY.
WE ALSO HOST
FREE FARMERS MARKETS,
WHERE WE'LL SET UP SHOP
IN AN IMPOVERISHED NEIGHBORHOOD,
BUY 5,000 POUNDS OF PRODUCE,
GIVE IT ALL AWAY.
EVAN, WHY BOTHER DOING THAT
WHILE YOU'RE UNPROFITABLE?
THAT'S HIS MARKETING
EXPENSE.
WHY WOULDN'T YOU --
EXACTLY.
IT'S A MARKETING EXPENSE.
IT'S SOCIAL VALUE.
IF YOU'RE NOT PROFITABLE,
YOU'RE NOT SUSTAINABLE.
IF YOU'RE NOT GROWING,
YOU'RE DYING.
♪♪
ALL-IN,
WHAT'S YOUR GROSS MARGIN?
SO, ON AVERAGE,
WE SELL THE BAGS FOR $19.
ON AVERAGE,
IT COSTS $8.25 TO MAKE.
SO ABOUT 50%.
THAT'S GONNA INCREASE
WITH SCALE, OBVIOUSLY.
THAT'S INCLUDING DELIVERY?
THAT IS INCLUDING DELIVERY,
ALL INCLUSIVE.
WOW.
I'M SITTING HERE LISTENING
TO YOU AND THINKING,
"WHAT A GREAT GUY THIS GUY IS."
BUT WHAT DISTURBS ME MORE
THAN ANYTHING ELSE
IS HOW MUCH YOU ARE IN LOVE
WITH THE IDEA.
I BELIEVE IN A BUSINESS
THAT'S GREEDY
AND WANTS TO MAKE A PROFIT
RUN BY GOOD PEOPLE,
LIKE MY BUSINESS
GRACE AND LACE.
THEY'RE MAKING $3 MILLION
THIS YEAR, $1 MILLION IN PROFIT.
BUT WHAT DO THEY DO WITH
THE $1 MILLION PROFIT
AFTER THEY GET
THEIR GREEDY PROFIT?
THEY OPEN ORPHANAGES.
FIVE OF THEM IN INDIA.
YOU'RE ALL GOOD. AND YOU DON'T
HAVE THE GRIT EXPERIENCE
THAT'S -- I THINK IT'S GONNA
TAKE TO BUILD ANY BUSINESS.
SO YOU -- MM-HMM.
ALL RIGHT?
SO I'M OUT.
THANK YOU, BARBARA.
I'M AN INVESTOR IN PLATED.
THEY HAVE HUNDREDS OF THOUSANDS
OF MEALS SHIPPED EVERY WEEK.
AND WE'VE GONE THROUGH
A LOT OF HARDSHIP
ON THE LOGISTICS
AS IT'S SCALED.
THEY'RE ABOUT --
THEY'RE ON THE RUN RATE
FOR $100 MILLION THIS YEAR.
RIGHT.
SO, YOU KNOW,
I'D LOVE TO SHOW YOU
HOW MANY MISTAKES WE MADE
BEFORE WE FIGURED IT OUT.
SURE.
I'D LOVE TO LEARN.
YEAH, PLAT--
YOU'D BE A GREAT PARTNER
FOR HIM.
Herjavec: I LIKE THE BRAND.
I LIKE WHAT YOU'RE DOING.
WHAT I'VE REALLY BEEN
LOOKING FOR --
INSTEAD OF JUST
WRITING ANOTHER CHECK,
I'VE BEEN LOOKING FOR A WAY
TO GIVE PEOPLE AN OPPORTUNITY
THAT EMPOWERS THEM.
SO I'M NOT GONNA ARGUE
WITH THE OTHER SHARKS.
I'M NOT GONNA TRY TO BID IT UP.
YOU CAME IN LOOKING
FOR $50,000 FOR 5%.
I'LL GIVE YOU $100,000
FOR 10%.
I CAN HELP YOU RUN
THIS BUSINESS.
I CAN HELP YOU SCALE IT.
I MEAN, THIS IS WHAT I DO.
SURE.
LET'S BUILD A GREAT BUSINESS.
LET'S GIVE PEOPLE HOPE.
LET'S EMPOWER THEM.
AND WE'LL MAKE THE MONEY.
THAT'S MY OFFER.
THANK YOU FOR THAT OFFER.
CAN I HEAR THE OTHER SHARKS,
AS WELL?
OHH!
I -- I DON'T KNOW WHY YOU
SHOULDN'T HEAR EVERY OFFER.
YEAH, I'M NOT GONNA
ARGUE WITH YOU.
YEAH, I UNDERSTAND.
I-I UNDERSTAND.
I REALLY APPRECIATE
YOUR OFFER.
I REALLY DO.
THIS DEFINITELY FITS IN
WHAT I'M DOING,
AND I KNOW A LOT OF THINGS
YOU DON'T KNOW YET
'CAUSE SCALING UP TO
$100 MILLION --
YOU WANT TO USE THIS FOR PLATED
AND GET THEM PRODUCE FOR PLATED.
[ LAUGHS ]
WELL, THERE'S A LOT OF SYNERGY
AND ALSO A LOT
OF LOGISTICS CENTERS,
AS WELL,
THAT WE HAVE CAPACITY IN.
THERE'S A LOT.
I LOOK AT IT --
I WANT MORE THAN 5%.
IT'S JUST TOO SMALL FOR ME.
I'D LIKE TO GET TO...
EVAN, LOOK.
I'D LIKE TO GET TO 10%.
LET ME FINISH MY OFFER.
EVAN,
I MADE YOU A FAIR OFFER.
SO SAY IT ALREADY.
IF YOU THINK THERE'S
A BETTER OFFER COMING,
I'M NOT TRYING TO BE
DISRESPECTFUL TO YOU...
YOU DON'T KNOW.
YOU HAVEN'T HEARD IT YET.
...BUT THERE'S NO POINT.
I MEAN, THIS IS SOMETHING
I WANT TO DO.
AND SO...
SO I'LL GIVE YOU --
I'M NOT GONNA ARGUE
WITH KEVIN ON IT.
DO YOU WANT TO HEAR
MY OFFER OR NOT?
I MEAN...
Greiner: EVAN, EVAN.
...EITHER TAKE
MY OFFER
OR ARGUE WITH KEVIN
AND MARK AND LORI.
ROBERT.
SPEAK UP, YOUNG MAN.
I'D LOVE TO ACCEPT YOUR OFFER.
WHOA!
THANK YOU.
YAY!
Cuban: SMART.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I DIDN'T WANT TO FORCE YOU
INTO IT,
BUT I THINK IT'S SUCH
A GREAT IDEA.
THANK YOU.
I REALLY APPRECIATE IT.
YOU WERE HONEST.
YOU WERE AWESOME.
THANK YOU SO MUCH.
I LOVE IT.
WE'LL BE IN TOUCH.
YEAH.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE A LOT
OF MONEY, OKAY?
THANK YOU.
THANK YOU. TAKE CARE, EVERYBODY.
NICE MEETING YOU, EVERYBODY.
Cuban: CONGRATULATIONS, EVAN.
GOOD LUCK. GOOD LUCK.
GREAT MISSION.
Lutz: TO MAKE A DEAL WITH ROBERT
FOR MORE THAN WHAT WE'RE ASKING,
IT'S JUST --
DREAMS DO COME TRUE.
I MEAN, IT'S REALLY...
I'M -- I'M SPEECHLESS.
I REALLY AM.
I'M SPEECHLESS.
♪♪
Narrator: NEXT INTO THE TANK
IS A SOLUTION FOR UNRULY HAIR.
HI, I'M ALANNA.
AND I'M MAUREEN.
AND WE ARE HAIR STYLISTS
AND CURLY-HAIR EXPERTS
FROM PORTLAND, MAINE.
WE ARE CONTROLLED CHAOS.
WE'RE SEEKING $50,000
FOR 20% OF THE COMPANY.
EVERYONE'S HEARD OF
A BAD HAIR DAY, RIGHT?
NEVER HAPPENS TO ME.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
BUT YOU'VE HEARD OF IT.
[ LAUGHS ]
HOW ABOUT
A BAD HAIR LIFE?
-WOW.
-WHOA.
SCHOOL ASSEMBLY DAYS
AND MOVIE DAYS
WERE THE STUFF OF NIGHTMARES
FOR MAUREEN AND I
GROWING UP AS KIDS.
YEAH, WE WOULD ACTUALLY
HEAR MEAN THINGS, LIKE,
"HOW YOU GONNA GET THROUGH
THE DOOR WITH THAT?"
"HEY, BRILLO PAD, MOVE THAT
FUZZ BALL YOU CALL A HEAD!"
"HEY, TEACHER, I CAN'T
SEE THE TV THROUGH HER."
[ EXAGGERATED LAUGHTER ]
[ Unenthused ]
HILARIOUS.
[ LAUGHTER ]
WE ACTUALLY BECAME HAIR STYLISTS
TO HELP OTHER PEOPLE
WITH THIS SO-CALLED
"PROBLEM" BAD HAIR
LEARN TO EMBRACE AND LOVE
THEIR NATURAL TEXTURE.
FIRST, YOU NEED A PRODUCT
THAT WORKS WITH YOUR CURL.
SOME SO-CALLED CURLY PRODUCTS
WILL ACTUALLY
HOLD THE CURL TOGETHER,
BUT IT ALWAYS RESULTS
IN A STICKY, CRUSTY,
CRUNCHY FEELING.
BUT NOW,
WITH CURL UP & SHINE,
YOU DON'T HAVE TO WORRY
ABOUT THAT ANYMORE.
I CAN GO OUT IN
ANY TYPE OF WEATHER.
SO WE NO LONGER HAVE TO
FEAR HUMIDITY, THE RAIN.
WE CAN EVEN GO TO THE BEACH.
AND WE JUST WANT TO SHOW
THE WORLD HOW GREAT
PEOPLE CAN FEEL ABOUT THEMSELVES
WHEN THEY REALIZE...
Both: ...THE CURLS
ARE NOT A CURSE.
LITTLE EXAMPLE FOR YOU GUYS
TO SEE WHICH SIDE OF THIS HEAD
YOU'D RATHER RUN
YOUR FINGERS THROUGH.
RUN YOUR HANDS THROUGH,
AND YOU CAN JUST...
WHICH SIDE, MARK?
[ LAUGHTER ]
THIS IS AN EXAMPLE.
NO, YOU CAN TELL THE DIFFERENCE.
IT'S OBVIOUS.
WHAT A DIFFERENCE.
RIGHT?
IT ALSO LOOKS VASTLY DIFFERENT,
DOESN'T IT?
THANK YOU.
YEAH.
OKAY, SO THERE'S DEFINITELY
A PLASTIC-Y FEEL
VERSUS FLUFFY.
VERY SOFT AND NATURAL.
WITH MEMORY. WITH MEMORY.
NOTHING.
SO ONE HAS, LIKE,
THE TYPICAL GEL ON IT,
AND ONE IS YOUR GEL?
FEEL IT, LORI.
Emerson: YES. CORRECT.
GOTCHA.
OURS IS A CREAM.
IT DOESN'T LEAVE
A RESIDUE.
YEAH.
IT SMELLS NICE.
SO, HOW MUCH DO YOU
HAVE IN SALES?
ALMOST $300,000.
OKAY,
WHERE DO YOU SELL THOSE?
HAIR SALONS.
WE ACTUALLY HAVE
10 PRODUCTS.
OKAY.
THIS IS THE ONLY ONE
THAT WE'RE MARKETING
BECAUSE WE WENT TOO BIG.
I ALWAYS BELIEVED IN
GO BIG OR GO HOME.
I DIDN'T THINK YOU COULD
GO BIG AND GO HOME.
SO WE HAVE A BUNCH
OF INVENTORY.
YOU KNOW, I WENT, LIKE,
TOO CRAZY
BECAUSE WE HAD
A DISTRIBUTION DEAL.
BUT, YOU KNOW,
HINDSIGHT'S 20/20.
IF I DIDN'T HAVE THIS DEAL
WITH THE DISTRIBUTOR
THAT REQUIRED THAT DEVELOP
A FULL LINE OF PRODUCT...
OY.
...I WOULD HAVE DONE
JUST A CURL CREAM,
SPENT $20,000 MARKETING
THE BEST CURL CREAM EVER SEEN
ON THE PLANET,
AND THEN GROW FROM THERE.
AND, ALANNA,
WHY IS THIS BAD NEWS?
DIDN'T THEY BUY
ALL THOSE PRODUCTS?
NO.
Corcoran: THEY PROMISED.
BECAUSE THIS WAS IN 2007.
SO HE NO LONGER OWNS
THE DISTRIBUTORSHIP.
MM.
AND IT'S -- YEAH.
WHAT DID YOU SELL LAST YEAR?
$85,000.
OUT OF THE $85,000,
HOW MUCH OF IT WAS THIS PRODUCT?
PROBABLY $30,000 WAS
THE CURL CREAM ALONE.
ARE YOU GROWING,
OR ARE YOU SLOWING?
OH, GROWING.
DEFINITELY.
WHICH IS IT?
GROWING.
WELL, TELL ME WHAT
THE NUMBERS ARE.
$30,000 THIS PAST YEAR
ON JUST THIS PRODUCT?
YEP.
AND HOW ABOUT
THE PRIOR YEARS?
IT'S ACTUALLY PROBABLY
BEEN ABOUT THE SAME
BECAUSE OUR SALES FOR
THE PAST TWO YEARS
HAVE BEEN ABOUT THE SAME.
WELL, THAT WOULD NOT BE GROWING.
THAT WOULD BE FLAT.
WELL...THIS...
THANK GOODNESS I'M HERE.
WE'RE [LAUGHS]
WE ACTUALLY HAVE
STOPPED ADVERTISING,
STOPPED SELLING ALTOGETHER
BECAUSE WE ARE --
THAT'S ALWAYS A GOOD SIGN
FOR A BUSINESS.
I KNOW, BUT I KNOW I CAN'T
AFFORD ANY MORE INVENTORY.
I MEAN, I HAVE A REALLY
GREAT MIND FOR BUSINESS.
NO, I DON'T THINK SO.
I BOUGHT MY FIRST HOUSE
AT 21.
I FIXED AND FLIPPED IT,
MADE MONEY KIND OF BY MISTAKE.
LIKE, I BELIEVE IN DOING
AWESOME THINGS
AND HAVING MONEY BE A BYPRODUCT
OF YOUR AWESOMENESS.
AND THEN I OPENED
MY OWN SALON
BECAUSE I DIDN'T LIKE THE DECOR
OF WHERE I WORKED.
I DIDN'T EVEN REALLY
WANT TO OWN A SALON.
NOW I OWN
A 5,000-SQUARE-FOOT SALON.
OKAY, WAIT, WAIT, WAIT,
THAT IS NOT AWESOMENESS
OF BUSINESS, RIGHT?
THAT'S CALLED
STUMBLING INTO THINGS.
BUT THIS BUSINESS --
YEAH.
THIS BUSINESS
I WAS COMPLETELY NAIVE,
WHICH I HATE TO ADMIT.
WE WERE SO UNDER-FUNDED.
I HAD NO IDEA WHAT I WAS
GETTING MYSELF INTO.
HOW MUCH OF YOUR OWN MONEY
DID YOU PUT IN?
YEAH, BUT YOU KNOW WHAT,
IT'S A VERY HARD --
IT'S A VERY HARD BUSINESS.
O'Leary: BUT HANG ON. HANG ON.
LET'S STOP FOR A MOMENT.
LET'S STOP FOR A MOMENT AND ASK
OURSELVES HOW'S IT GOING?
YOU'RE IN THE SHARK TANK.
HORRIBLY!
THAT'S WHY WE'RE HERE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
I'M TALKING --
THAT'S EXCITING TO HEAR.
WAIT, WAIT, HOW MUCH
MONEY HAVE YOU PUT IN?
I HAVE OVER $300,000 IN IT.
OHH!
WHAT?!
BUT I HAVE ANOTHER BUSINESS.
I HAVE A HAIR SALON.
ALANNA, WHO'S MAUREEN?
MAUREEN IS OUR EDUCATOR.
I'M AN EDUCATOR
AND STYLIST.
SHE TEACHES --
DOES SHE OWN THE BUSINESS?
NO, SHE CREATED THE PRODUCTS
WITH ME FROM DAY ONE.
MAUREEN, HOW DO YOU THINK
ALANNA'S PRESENTATION'S GOING
HERE IN THE SHARK TANK?
I THINK, UH, THAT THERE'S
A LOT OF OPPORTUNITY FOR GROWTH.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SO SHE'S A POLITICIAN.
Greiner: ALANNA,
LET ME ASK YOU A QUESTION.
Cuban:
OH, MY GOODNESS.
SO, YOU'RE A HAIR DRESSER.
YOU'VE OPENED UP SALONS.
AND THAT SALON DOES
$1 MILLION A YEAR
IN A POPULATION
WITH 60,000 PEOPLE.
GOOD FOR YOU.
SO I KNOW WHAT I'M DOING.
THANKS.
YOU DECIDE TO YOURSELF,
"I'D LIKE TO HAVE A LINE."
LIKE, ALMOST EVERY HAIR DRESSER
I'VE EVER KNOWN
WANTS THEIR OWN LINE, RIGHT?
MM-HMM.
BUT YOU HAVE A SECRET SAUCE HERE
YOU THINK IS BETTER
THAN ANYBODY ELSE'S.
I KNOW IS.
WHY IS YOURS BETTER?
FOR ONE, IT WORKS.
NOTHING ELSE REALLY WORKS.
OKAY. WHY WOULD YOU NOT
JUST TAKE THIS
AND JUST TRY TO PUSH
THAT ONE THING, LIKE,
INTO SALLY BEAUTY
AND INTO THE DIFFERENT WAYS
IN WHICH YOU CAN DISTRIBUTE IT?
WE HAVE BEEN TOLD
BY ONE OF THE LARGEST
INDEPENDENT DISTRIBUTORS
IN THE COUNTRY THAT THEY WOULD
GIVE US A PURCHASE ORDER
BEGINNING WITH
500 UNITS A MONTH OF THAT
IF WE CHANGE OUR PACKAGING.
THAT'S WHAT WE'RE HERE FOR.
YEAH, YOUR PACKAGING
NEEDS A CHANGE.
I'M OUT OF MONEY.
MY OTHER BUSINESS
IS SUFFERING.
HOW MUCH LONGER?
I MEAN, AT SOME POINT --
DO YOU SELL THIS ONLINE?
AND IF SO, WHAT DO YOU CHARGE
FOR WHAT I'M HOLDING IN MY HAND?
8 OUNCE FOR $39.
$39. IS THAT A LOT FOR
THAT KIND OF PRODUCT?
WOW!
BELIEVE IT OR NOT, I ACTUALLY
HAVE VERY CURLY HAIR.
I JUST KEEP IT VERY SHORT.
[ LAUGHTER ]
GOOD IDEA.
WHEN I WAS IN HIGH SCHOOL,
MY HAIR WAS DOWN TO
MY SHOULDERS AND WAS CURLY.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO
WITH $50,000?
I WOULD LIKE TO RE-BRAND,
RE-PACKAGE, AND --
WHAT WOULD THAT COST?
I'M SURE YOU'VE --
WELL, I HOPE YOU'VE
PRICED THAT OUT.
$50,000.
YOU GET $50,000,
BUT NOW YOU HAVE NO MONEY LEFT
FOR ADVERTISING AND PROMOTION.
WELL, I'M THINKING IF
I HAD $50,000,
THIS IS WHAT IT WOULD COST ME
TO RE-BRAND AND REFILL
AND GO TO THE DISTRIBUTOR
AND DO THE PURCHASE ORDER
THAT WE CURRENTLY HAVE.
RIGHT.
I'M GUESSING THAT $50,000
TO YOU GUYS
IS WORTH A LOT MORE
THAN $50,000, SO...
WHAT DOES THAT MEAN?
WITH YOUR CONNECTIONS
THAT YOU HAVE.
I BELIEVE IN IT SO MUCH,
SO --
I DON'T INVEST IN "BELIEVE."
I INVEST IN "DO."
I'M OUT.
GOTCHA. THANK YOU.
SO, YOU KNOW, IT'S BEEN
A VERY INTERESTING JOURNEY
LISTENING TO YOU
BECAUSE, OBVIOUSLY,
YOU HAVE A PRODUCT
THAT DOES ONE THING VERY WELL.
I BELIEVE THAT.
BUT YOUR STORY IS ONE
OF CHAOS AND CONFUSION.
[ CHUCKLES ]
I THINK YOU CALLED
YOUR BUSINESS THAT.
[ LAUGHS ]
CONTROLLED CHAOS.
NO, THE NAME IS NOT
IT'S JUST CHAOS.
BUT IF YOU WANT TO
TALK ABOUT HAIR,
I CAN TALK ABOUT HAIR.
[ LAUGHS ]
50% OF THE WOMEN HAVE
CURLY HAIR, RIGHT?
60%.
-ISN'T THAT THE STAT IN AMERICA?
-60%?
-THEY HAVE A PROBLEM. I BELIEVE.
SO HERE'S THE DEAL
I'M WILLING TO OFFER YOU.
OH, THERE'S AN OFFER?
♪♪
Narrator: ONE SHARK IS OUT.
MAUREEN AND ALANNA
HAVE NOT IMPRESSED THE SHARKS
WITH THEIR BUSINESS ACUMEN.
BUT KEVIN KNOWS
THERE'S A HUGE MARKET
FOR THEIR HAIR CREAM FOR
CURLY HAIR -- CONTROLLED CHAOS.
50% OF THE WOMEN HAVE
CURLY HAIR, RIGHT? ISN'T
THAT THE STAT IN AMERICA?
60%.
60%?
THEY HAVE A PROBLEM.
I BELIEVE.
SO HERE'S THE DEAL
I'M WILLING TO OFFER YOU.
OH, THERE'S AN OFFER?
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $50,000.
I WANT 50%, ALL RIGHT?
AND I DON'T WANT TO TALK
ABOUT ANYTHING ELSE.
I WANT NOTHING TO DO WITH
ALL THE REST OF THOSE PRODUCTS.
IT'S A GREAT OFFER.
IT'S JUST THIS PRODUCT.
[ CHUCKLES ]
Cuban: HMM.
YOU BETTER SAY YES BEFORE
SOMEBODY CHANGES THEIR MIND.
YOU KNOW WHAT THIS MEANS
AT AUCTIONS?
WELL, THERE ARE TWO GIRLS,
TOO, RIGHT?
$51,000.
YOU'RE GIVING HER $1,000?
$51,000. 50%.
SHE'S STARTING AN AUCTION.
[ BOTH LAUGH ]
I GOT THE BIDDING GOING
BECAUSE I KNOW HAIR.
ARE YOU ABSOLUTELY CERTAIN THAT
THIS IS THE BEST PRODUCT OUT
FOR WOMEN WITH CURLY HAIR?
YES.
ABSOLUTELY.
I THINK I TRUST YOUR GUT
CREATIVELY 150%.
YEAH.
BUT I DON'T TRUST YOU
FOR A SECOND
ON KNOWING HOW TO REIN THINGS IN
AND MAKE IT GET DIRECTED
EXACTLY AT THE TARGET
THAT YOU NEED TO HIT.
RIGHT.
I WANT 51% OF YOUR BUSINESS.
[ WHIMPERS ]
FOR $50,000,
I WANT THE MAJORITY SHARE
OF YOUR BUSINESS.
BUT I DON'T WANT 51% OF
THE REVENUE OR THE DIVIDENDS.
I'LL TAKE 1/3.
BUT I WANT TO MAKE SURE
YOU GET TO WHERE YOU WANT TO GO
BECAUSE I'M GREAT AT BUILDING
A BUSINESS.
INTERESTING OFFER.
YOU'RE THE CREATIVE GENIUS HERE,
BUT IF YOU'RE A SMART WOMAN,
YOU WOULD HAND ME THE CONTROL
BECAUSE I KNOW HOW TO
BUILD BUSINESSES.
AND I'M NOT TAKING MORE THAN
MY FAIR SHARE OF THE PROFITS,
WHICH WE WILL HAVE.
I'M ONLY TAKING 1/3
OF THE PROFITS.
YOU UNDERSTAND THAT OFFER?
AND WHAT'S...
ALL RIGHT, I'M BACK.
York: YES.
THIS -- THIS I HAVE
TO THINK ABOUT.
WAIT, WAIT, WAIT.
LORI'S GONNA ADJUST HER OFFER.
ALTHOUGH I WANTED TO
SAY YES.
[ LAUGHS ]
WELL, THEN, SAY YES!
[ LAUGHTER ]
$60,000. 50%.
I KNOW HOW TO MOVE PRODUCT,
LIKE, LIGHTNING SPEED.
I THINK I CAN MOVE
A LOT OF UNITS.
WE GOT TO REPACKAGE.
BUT I CAN GET IT OUT THERE
ON QVC
FOR THAT 60% OF WOMEN
WITH CURLY HAIR.
BUT I'D LIKE YOU TO TAKE
MY OFFER NOW BECAUSE IT'S,
LIKE, GOING, GOING, GOING.
O'Leary:
WAIT A SECOND.
YOU DON'T HAVE TO FALL
FOR THAT TRICK.
ROBERT HASN'T SAID
IF HE'S IN OR OUT.
YOU DON'T HAVE
TO BE WORRIED.
YOU'RE IN CHARGE HERE.
IF YOU KNOW IF I'M RIGHT
FOR YOU...
TWO OFFERS ON THE TABLE.
I CAN'T BELIEVE HOW MANY
SHARKS ARE --
ALANNA, LET ME JUST
CLEAR THE FIELD.
YOU'VE GOT THREE GOOD OFFERS
HERE, AMAZING TO ME.
[ LAUGHS ]
I DO.
I LOVE YOUR HONESTY.
YOU KNOW, YOU SEE -- YOU'VE
GOT THREE GREAT OFFERS.
I'M OUT.
BUT LORI IS MAKING YOU AN OFFER
WITH A DEADLINE.
Greiner:
I LIKE THE PRODUCT,
AND I BELIEVE THAT YOU
CAN BE A GREAT PARTNER.
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA DO?
I HAVE BEEN ON QVC FOR
TWO YEARS IN MY HEAD, SO...
OH!
Herjavec:
SO WHAT?! WHAT?!
LET'S DO IT!
LET'S DO IT, LORI!
ARE YOU TAKING HER OFFER,
OR...?
[ LAUGHS ] YES.
OHH, WHAT A MISTAKE!
[ LAUGHTER ]
YOU DODGED A BULLET.
I DIDN'T.
YOU MADE A MISTAKE.
Greiner: I LIKE IT.
I LOVE YOU, TOO.
WE'LL MAKE IT HAPPEN.
I DON'T LOVE YOU BACK
RIGHT NOW.
WE'LL MAKE IT HAPPEN.
ALANNA, I'M OUT.
THANK YOU.
Cuban: THANKS, GUYS.
Greiner: THANK YOU.
BYE.
Corcoran: BYE-BYE.
THANK YOU.
WHO SAW THAT COMING?
ONLY ON "SHARK TANK"
DO WE GET A BIDDING WAR
OVER A DYING BUSINESS.
THAT'S GONNA SELL.
IT'S GOING TO SELL.
THAT'S NOT GONNA SELL.
I KNOW HAIR.
[ LAUGHS ]
IT'S...
JUST NOT
ON YOUR HEAD, KEVIN.
GAH!
[ Singsong voice ]
AMAZING.
[ LAUGHS ]
♪♪
Narrator: IN SEASON 6,
WE WATCHED ANNA STORK
AND ANDREA SRESHTA
MAKE A DEAL WITH MARK CUBAN
FOR THEIR SOLAR-POWER LIGHTS
COMPANY LuminAID.
MARK, I THINK
YOU GOT A DEAL.
THANK YOU.
LET'S SEE WHAT
THEY'RE DOING NOW.
Sreshta:
OUR MISSION HAS ALWAYS BEEN
TO HELP PEOPLE
AROUND THE WORLD
WITH OUR SOLAR-POWERED
INFLATABLE LIGHTS.
SO THIS IS OUR NEW PRODUCT,
AND IT LASTS FOR OVER 30 HOURS.
WITH MARK'S INVESTMENT,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO GROW
OUR COMPANY
AND REACH EVEN MORE PEOPLE
IN NEED.
AND OUR SALES
CONTINUE TO RISE.
IN THE YEAR BEFORE
"SHARK TANK,"
WE DID JUST OVER $1 MILLION
IN SALES.
IT'S BEEN NINE MONTHS,
AND WE'VE ALREADY DONE
$2 MILLION IN SALES.
Stork: THROUGH MARK,
WE'VE BEEN ABLE TO
LAND DEALS WITH COMPANIES
LIKE ZULILY, BROOKSTONE,
AND THE CONTAINER STORE.
BUT THE MOST REWARDING WORK
WE'VE DONE
IS WITH ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
CUSTOMERS -- SHELTERBOX.
[ MAN SPEAKING NATIVE LANGUAGE ]
WE'VE RECENTLY JOINED
SHELTERBOX
ON A HUMANITARIAN TRIP
TO MALAWI.
THEY RESPOND TO DISASTERS
ALL AROUND THE WORLD
BY PROVIDING BOXES
OF NECESSITIES.
EARLIER THIS YEAR, MALAWI
WAS HIT BY THE WORST FLOODS
THE COUNTRY HAD SEEN
IN 40 YEARS,
AND OVER 200,000 PEOPLE
WERE LEFT HOMELESS.
THESE PEOPLE HAVE
LOST EVERYTHING,
AND THEY'RE SO GRATEFUL
FOR A LIGHT.
IT MEANS SO MUCH TO US
TO SEE WHAT A BIG DIFFERENCE
A LuminAID LIGHT CAN MAKE
IN THEIR LIVES.
THIS IS
THE SOLAR PANEL HERE.
WE'VE DISTRIBUTED MORE THAN
$50,000 LuminAID LIGHTS
IN EMERGENCY SITUATIONS
IN MORE THAN 50 COUNTRIES.
OUR GOAL IS TO CONTINUE TO
GET INTO MORE RETAIL STORES,
INNOVATE NEW PRODUCTS,
AND PROVIDE OUR LIGHTS TO
AID MISSIONS AROUND THE WORLD.
AS YOUNG WOMEN IN BUSINESS,
IT'S AN INCREDIBLY HUMBLING
FEELING TO BE ABLE TO DO
WHAT WE DO AND INSPIRE OTHERS
IN THE PROCESS.
WE'RE SO GRATEFUL
FOR OUR EXPERIENCE
AND KNOW THAT OUR FUTURE
IS BRIGHTER THAN EVER
WITH THE HELP OF MARK
AND "SHARK TANK."
♪♪
Narrator:
NEXT INTO THE TANK IS A SOLUTION
FOR MESSY LITTLE EATERS.
♪♪
HI, MY NAME'S LINDSEY LAURAIN,
AND I'M FROM PARKER, COLORADO.
I AM THE FOUNDER OF EZPZ,
AND TODAY,
I AM SEEKING $1 MILLION
FOR A 5% STAKE IN MY COMPANY.
WOW!
DANG!
HEAR ME OUT. HEAR ME OUT.
WHEW!
HEAR ME OUT.
THANKS FOR COMING.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
[ LAUGHTER ]
SHARKS, WHO HAS RECENTLY
HAD OR WITNESSED
MEAL TIME WITH A TODDLER?
IN OUR CASE, THREE TODDLERS.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK
AT WHAT MEAL TIME
USED TO LOOK LIKE AT OUR HOUSE.
[ LAUGHTER ]
UGH.
YOUR KIDS ARE SLOBS.
MOMMY.
[ SCREAMING ]
[ LAUGHTER ]
HONESTLY, THAT WAS WHAT MEALTIME
USED TO LOOK LIKE AT OUR HOUSE.
IT WAS CRAZY.
MY HUSBAND AND I KNEW
THERE HAD TO BE A BETTER WAY,
SO WE CREATED IT.
THE HAPPY MAT IS AN ALL-IN-ONE
SILICONE PLACE MAT AND PLATE.
BUT THE BEST PART IS THE MAT
SUCTIONS TO THE SURFACE.
SO THIS MEANS
NO MORE TIPPED BOWLS OR PLATES
DURING MEAL TIME.
CLEVER.
THE HAPPY MAT NAME
REALLY SAYS IT ALL.
THE SMILEY-FACE DESIGN CREATES
A POSITIVE FEEDING EXPERIENCE.
THERE IS TRULY NOTHING LIKE
EZPZ ON THE MARKET.
WE ARE REVOLUTIONIZING
THE FEEDING INDUSTRY
THROUGHOUT THE WORLD.
LET'S TAKE A LOOK AT WHAT
MEALTIME LOOKS LIKE NOW.
[ UP-TEMPO MUSIC PLAYS ]
ARE THESE THE SAME KIDS?
[ LAUGHTER ]
Greiner:
THEY'RE BEING VERY GOOD.
[ ALL CHEERING ]
Boy: I LOVE EZPZ.
YOU SEDATED THEM.
OH, COME ON.
YOU PAID THEM TO SAY THAT.
[ LAUGHS ]
LINDSEY, WE GOT TO GO
RIGHT TO THE SALES BECAUSE --
GOT TO GO RIGHT
TO THE NUMBERS.
NO, SAMPLES!
GONNA HAVE
A GOOD STORY THERE.
NO, COME ON. COME ON!
SAMPLES!
$20 MILLION!
SAMPLES.
Laurain: OKAY.
Herjavec: IS THERE FOOD
IN THE SAMPLES?
YES, AS I SAID...
THE BOTTOM ONE IS LORI'S?
YEP. GRAY IS LORI.
ALL RIGHT.
THERE YOU GO, LORI.
[ LAUGHS ]
THANK YOU.
AND AS I SAID,
YOU CAN STACK AND SERVE
EVERYBODY AT THE SAME TIME,
SO...
IT'S SO CUTE.
OH, IT'S VERY CUTE.
AND
THE SMILEY-FACE DESIGN...
HOW NICE IS THAT?
...REALLY DOES CREATE
A POSITIVE FEEDING EXPERIENCE.
BLUE --
YOUR FAVORITE COLOR.
WHAT'S THE LITTLE EYEBALL
ON THERE?
THANK YOU.
YOU'RE WELCOME.
Corcoran: I'M JUST CURIOUS
WHAT YOU SELL ONE MAT FOR.
YES, SO, ONE MAT RETAILS
FOR $24.99.
OUR WHOLESALE PRICE IS $12.50,
AND THEN WE HAVE
A 50% MARGIN WITH THAT.
SO YOU MAKE IT FOR
ABOUT 6 BUCKS?
YES, A LITTLE BIT --
AROUND THAT.
SO, LINDSEY, YOU'VE IMPUTED
A VALUE -- $1 MILLION, 5%.
SO YOU'RE TELLING ME THIS
BUSINESS IS WORTH $20 MILLION.
LET'S GO TO THE NUMBERS NOW!
Laurain: YES.
SO, WHAT -- I THINK THAT'S THE
ONLY THING WE GOT TO TALK ABOUT.
OKAY.
BECAUSE THAT IS SUCH
A CRAZY ASK,
UNLESS YOU HAVE
PHENOMENAL SALES.
OKAY, SO, YES, OUR SALES
ARE VERY STRONG, AND --
TELL US WHAT THEY ARE.
I'LL BE HONEST --
I WANTED TO DO FIVE TIMES
THAT VALUATION.
FIVE TIMES?
OUT WITH IT.
WHAT -- IN THIS CALENDAR YEAR,
WHAT ARE YOU GONNA SELL?
SO, WE'VE DONE 85,000 UNITS
THIS YEAR
AT $1.2 MILLION GROSS SALES.
THAT'S IT?
-YEP.
-[ LAUGHS ]
SO I'M GONNA PAY
16 TIMES SALES
FOR A RUBBER MAT
WITH A FACE ON IT?
ARE YOU EXPECTING, LIKE,
TO DO $30 MILLION
THIS YEAR OR SOMETHING?
WAY MORE THAN $30 MILLION.
SO, LIKE, LAST WEEK,
WE WERE IN GERMANY AT
THE WORLD'S LARGEST BABY SHOW.
WE MET WITH 400 INTERNATIONAL
DISTRIBUTORS.
WE WERE THE HIT OF THE SHOW.
SO WE'VE GOTTEN 400 CONTACTS,
EVERY COUNTRY, AUSTRALIA.
I'M ASSUMING
YOU HAVE A PATENT.
DO YOU TAKE ORDERS
AT A SHOW LIKE THAT?
DO YOU TAKE ORDERS?
YEAH, SO, WE SOLD --
NOT ON THE SPOT.
I MEAN, AUSTRALIA HAS SAID
THEY'LL TAKE A CONTAINER.
THEY WOULD DO A 40-FOOT
CONTAINER EVERY MONTH.
DO YOU HAVE A PATENT?
WE HAVE FILED AN I.P. PORTFOLIO.
SO WE FILED A UTILITY PATENT.
FILED.
WE HAVE A DESIGN PATENT.
SO WE'RE PATENT-PENDING.
YOU HAVE A DESIGN PATENT.
YOU'RE PATENT-PENDING.
SO LET'S ASSUME YOU'RE
SUCCESSFUL, AND YOU
ACHIEVE FULL PATENT.
YEAH, WE HAVE TO ASSUME
YOU'RE GONNA GET A PATENT.
SO LET'S ASSUME THAT.
OKAY.
I COULD TALK ABOUT THE OTHER --
IT DOESN'T MEAN
THAT SOMEBODY --
WE SHOULDN'T
ASSUME THAT?
NO.
NO. WHY WOULD YOU ASSUME?
YOU SHOULDN'T
ASSUME THAT.
NO. OKAY.
BUT LET'S JUST SAY -- I'M
TRYING TO BE THE UPSIDE CASE.
I AM ACTUALLY TRYING TO
FIGURE OUT HOW IT'S POSSIBLE,
UNDER ANY SCENARIO
ON THIS PLANET EARTH,
THAT THIS BUSINESS TODAY
IS WORTH $20 MILLION.
HOW MUCH MONEY DID YOU MAKE
ON THE $1.2 MILLION IN SALES?
SO, WE'VE NETTED
APPROXIMATELY 14%.
♪♪
YOU'VE MADE $140,000.
THAT WAS YOUR EARNINGS.
YEAH.
HOW DO YOU GET TO
$20 MILLION?
UM...OVER -- SO WE DID
LITERALLY FIVE YEARS,
I DID NET PRESENT VALUE --
FOUR TIMES EARNINGS
WITH A 45% DISCOUNT.
YOU'RE --
JUST SO I'M CLEAR --
YOU TOOK WHAT YOU THINK
YOU'RE GONNA EARN
IN THE NEXT FIVE YEARS,
TOTALED THAT UP,
AND GOT TO $20 MILLION TODAY?
YES.
WELL...
DO YOU SEE A PROBLEM
IN THAT?
I HONESTLY -- I DON'T BECAUSE
THERE'S SO MUCH OPPORTUNITY.
[ LAUGHS ]
I'LL BE HONEST.
SO, WHEN WE WERE
IN GERMANY LAST WEEK,
I MET WITH FOUR DIFFERENT
C.E.O.s FROM MASSIVE COMPANIES,
AND TWO HAVE SINCE SENT MESSAGES
ABOUT ACQUIRING US.
THEN WHY ARE YOU HERE, THOUGH?
WHY ARE YOU HERE?
I -- SO, I'LL EXPLAIN.
SO, THERE'S A FEW DIFFERENT
REASONS.
I'M TRYING TO BE KIND BEFORE
I ABSOLUTELY EVISCERATE YOU.
I'M HOLDING BACK.
OH, MY GOSH. BE NICE.
I CAN EXPLAIN.
SO I'M HERE FOR --
SO, THE BABY MARKET,
WE'RE ACTUALLY DOING
PHENOMENAL.
WE'VE GOT --
WE'RE IN NORDSTROM.
WE'RE SOLD ON AMAZON,
BUY BUY BABY, BABIES "R" US.
ARE YOU IN ALL
BUY BUY BABY STORES?
SO, WE ARE WAITING TO
ENTER BUY BUY BABY.
SO YOU'RE NOT
IN BUY BUY BABY?
NO, BUT THEY --
WE MET WITH THEM.
AND THEN WE'RE AT ABOUT
200 BOUTIQUES
THROUGHOUT THE COUNTRY.
OUR VALUATION HAS --
IN FIVE YEARS,
WE'LL BE IN 2,000 STORES.
NO, NO, BUT HANG ON,
LINDSEY.
WE EXPECT THAT.
BUT HOW MANY DO YOU SELL
IN EACH BOUTIQUE?
SO, WE -- YEP, WE -- WELL,
THE VALUATION IS ON AVERAGE,
WE HAVE 500 MATS PER YEAR
PER BOUTIQUE.
SO NEXT YEAR, THE BEST CASE IS
$5 MILLION IN SALES, YOU THINK?
I PERSONALLY THINK WE'LL DO
$10 MILLION IN SALES NEXT YEAR.
SO, FROM ALL THIS, YOU'VE
CREATED $1.2 MILLION IN SALES.
YOU'RE GONNA MAKE $140,000
BEFORE YOU PAY YOURSELF.
YOU'RE OPTIMISTIC THAT
NEXT YEAR'S $10 MILLION, RIGHT?
YEP.
AFTER THAT, $20 MILLION?
WHEN YOU LOOK AT AUSTRALIA,
THIS IS ONE EXAMPLE
OF HUNDREDS OF COUNTRIES
WE MET.
YOU KNOW, A CONTAINER
IS $50,000, $100,000 ORDER.
THEY SAID THEY WOULD BE ORDERING
A CONTAINER EVERY MONTH.
WHO? WHO SAID THAT?
OH, DISTRIBUTORS.
DID THEY GIVE YOU AN ORDER?
YEAH. UM...
YOU DON'T EVEN KNOW
IF IT'S SOLD THROUGH.
OH, YEAH. YES.
YOU HAVEN'T EVEN SHIPPED
THE FIRST ORDER TO AUSTRALIA.
I LOVE THE OPTIMISM.
YEAH.
BUT YOU DON'T HAVE ANY DATA.
YOU COME IN HERE ASKING FOR
A $20 MILLION VALUATION.
YOU KNOW WE'RE GONNA BE
SKEPTICAL.
YEP.
YOU KNOW YOU'RE GONNA
HAVE TO HAVE SOME DATA.
STOP TELLING ME AUSTRALIA'S
GONNA TAKE SO MANY CONTAINERS.
OH, BUT THAT'S ONE.
SO WE'RE IN CANADA.
WE'RE IN SOUTH KOREA.
WE'RE IN --
LOOK,
YOU'RE ALL OVER THE MAP.
I LIKE TO BUILD A SOLID BUSINESS
ON A SOLID FOUNDATION.
WHEN YOU ASK FOR $20 MILLION,
YOU BETTER HAVE SOLID DATA,
NOT A STORY. I'M OUT.
TO ME,
IT'S LIKE SHARKONOMICS 101.
IF YOU COME IN WITH TOO HIGH
A VALUATION,
YOU'VE GOT A PROBLEM.
YEP.
YOU KNOW, THE ENTHUSIASM FOR IT,
I GET IT,
BUT I SEE A HUGE CONCERN
WITH THE PATENT,
A HUGE CONCERN WITH IT
BEING VERY EARLY ON,
AND SO FOR THAT REASON,
I'M OUT.
THANK YOU FOR YOUR TIME.
THE WAY I LOOK AT IT IS THE RISK
IS ALL ON ME AS THE INVESTOR.
I TRY AND TRANSLATE
YOUR OPTIMISM AND YOUR I.P.,
WHICH HASN'T CLEARED YET.
ALL OF THESE THINGS
ARE UNKNOWNS.
ON THE OTHER HAND,
A MILLION BUCKS IS A LOT FOR 5%.
SO HERE'S A DEAL
THAT I'LL MAKE YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $1 MILLION
FOR 5%.
IF YOU DON'T HIT $10 MILLION
NEXT YEAR IN SALES, I GET 20%.
YOU'RE THROWING ALL THE RISK
BACK ON HER.
♪♪
Narrator:
TWO SHARKS ARE OUT.
KEVIN HAS MADE A CREATIVE OFFER
IN ORDER TO ENSURE AGAINST
LINDSEY'S OPTIMISTIC
SALES PROJECTIONS.
SO, HERE'S A DEAL
THAT I'LL MAKE YOU.
I'LL GIVE YOU THE $1 MILLION
FOR 5%.
IF YOU DON'T HIT $10 MILLION
NEXT YEAR IN SALES,
I GET 20%.
YOU'RE THROWING ALL THE RISK
BACK ON HER.
BECAUSE I THINK THE BUSINESS
TODAY IS WORTH 5 MILLION BUCKS
IF YOUR PATENT CLEARS.
'CAUSE I DON'T KNOW
HOW TO VALUE THIS BUSINESS.
I APPRECIATE --
I AM HUMBLED, BUT I --
BUT YOU TOLD ME
YOU'RE VERY OPTIMISTIC.
SO I GOT TO BUY INTO IT,
RIGHT?
I MEAN, IF YOU COULD
GO AND SEE THE RESPONSE.
I MEAN, WE WERE AT
THE WORLD'S LARGEST --
YEAH, NO, NO, NO, NO, NO.
LINDSEY, LINDSEY,
DON'T GO THERE. DON'T GO THERE.
LINDSEY, YOU'RE TALKING
IN CIRCLES NOW.
O'Leary:
MARK, WHAT ARE YOU DOING?
I'M NOT GONNA DO A DEAL
WITH YOU NO MATTER WHAT
BECAUSE I WOULD GO NUTS.
Corcoran: WHAT DISTURBS ME IS
YOU ARE GIVING US A PRICE TODAY
ON WHAT THE BUSINESS WILL BE
WORTH FOUR OR FIVE YEARS OUT.
BUT I'LL GIVE YOU
THE $1 MILLION.
BUT I WANT TO PAY IT OVER
FOUR YEARS -- $250,000 A YEAR.
OKAY.
THE RESTRICTIONS ON THAT --
ARE YOU HAPPY WITH THE 5%?
YES, I AM HAPPY WITH THE 5%
BECAUSE I TOTALLY
BELIEVE IN HER.
I THINK YOU HAVE GOT
A RUNAWAY PRODUCT,
BUT I THINK
YOU'RE YOUR OWN WORST ENEMY
BECAUSE OF YOUR OPTIMISM.
I THINK YOU NEED
A HEAVYWEIGHT,
SEASONED PERSON
WHO HAS BUILT BUSINESSES.
YEAH.
THE LAST THING I'M GONNA DO
IS THROW $1 MILLION AT YOU.
I THINK WHAT I HAVE TO WORK INTO
THE DEAL ARE TWO CONTINGENCIES.
I THINK, ONE, I HAVE TO KNOW
THAT YOU GET THE PATENT.
YEAH.
SECONDLY,
I THINK WE HAVE TO ESTABLISH
THE BENCHMARKS
YOU CITED OVER --
I'M HAPPY TO PAY OUT
THE MONEY OVER FOUR YEARS --
OVER FOUR YEARS,
YOU HIT THOSE TARGETS.
AND SO I -- I --
I APPRECIATE THAT OFFER.
AND I'D LOVE TO ASK
YOU GUYS --
SO, MR. WONDERFUL,
WHAT IS YOUR VISION,
IF YOU'RE GONNA BE INVOLVED
IN THE COMPANY?
WHAT DO YOU SEE THAT YOU WOULD
DO FOR THE PRODUCT?
MY CONCERNS ARE THIS -- I'M
GONNA HELP YOU WITH THE LEGALS,
ASSUMING THIS PATENT
ACTUALLY GETS ISSUED
BECAUSE THIS IS GONNA
GET KNOCKED OFF,
AND I WILL PROTECT IT.
NUMBER TWO,
I WILL MAKE THIS FAMOUS ONLINE.
THERE'S NO QUESTION
ABOUT THAT.
I DON'T THINK YOU'VE
REALLY MAXIMIZED THAT.
SO MY FOCUS IN THE SHORT TERM
WOULD BE TO ACTUALLY WORK HARD,
THAT YOU DID HIT
THE $10 MILLION,
AND I ONLY STAYED AT 5%.
YOU SEE WHAT I'M SAYING?
YEAH.
I'D RATHER YOU MADE IT
'CAUSE I THINK THE CHANCE
OF THIS BEING ACQUIRED IS HIGH.
AND I'M THINKING ABOUT CHANGING
MY OFFER AS I'M SITTING HERE.
I HAVE TO BE HONEST. I AM
IN A VERY GENEROUS MOOD TODAY.
SEE, THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS,
LINDSEY.
YOU HAD TWO OFFERS.
YOU'RE LETTING THEM GO.
WELL, NO, AND I, HONESTLY --
I --
MAKE A DECISION.
STOP SELLING.
♪♪
OKAY, I THINK THE DECISION IS
I THINK I'M GONNA MOVE ON.
YOU'RE TURNING DOWN
THE OFFERS?
BOTH OFFERS?
YEAH, I JUST -- I --
I HONESTLY -- I'M MORE JUST...
[ CHUCKLES ]
I'M MORE SAD THE WAY
THIS WAS PORTRAYED
BECAUSE OUR SALES ARE STRONG AND
WE HAVE ALL THOSE RELATIONSHIPS,
AND I FEEL --
BUT, LINDSEY, HE GAVE YOU
WHAT YOU WERE ASKING FOR.
HE GAVE YOU THE $1 MILLION
FOR THE SAME EQUITY
BASED ON WHAT YOU SAID --
THE WORDS THAT CAME OUT
OF YOUR MOUTH.
ABSOLUTELY, BUT IT'S BASED ON
CONTINGENCIES OF SELLING.
BUT IT'S WHAT YOU SAID!
BUT THERE SHOULD BE
NO RISK THERE.
THAT SHOULD BE
A SLAM DUNK.
BUT YOU SAID IT.
AND --
WHY DID YOU SAY IT
IF YOU DIDN'T MEAN IT?
I WANT TO DRAW A PARALLEL
BETWEEN YOU AND I...
YEAH.
...'CAUSE I WAS IN YOUR SHOES,
WITH WILD ENTHUSIASM,
WANTING TO BE THE QUEEN
OF NEW YORK REAL ESTATE
WHEN I WAS 22 YEARS OLD.
YEAH.
WHAT WAS SO IMPORTANT
IN MY JOURNEY
TO MAKE IT WASN'T MY OPTIMISM,
WHICH I HAD IN SPADES,
BUT IT WAS THE SELF DOUBT
AND THE INSECURITY THAT I FELT
ALL ALONG THE WAY
THAT MADE ME PAUSE AND THINK,
"OH, MY GOD,
I BETTER BE CAREFUL.
CAN I DO IT?
HOW WILL I MAKE IT?
WHO DO I USE?
WHO DO I TRUST?"
MY JUDGMENT CARD
BUILT MY BUSINESS.
YOU'RE A WILD-ASS,
ENTHUSIASTIC ENTREPRENEUR,
VERY CAPABLE.
YOU'VE GOT A GREAT PRODUCT.
ALL THAT'S FINE, BUT YOU'RE
MISSING THE SELF-DOUBT CARD.
WELL SAID, BARBARA.
OKAY, I'M SORRY.
I JUST --
LIKE I SAID, CULTURALLY,
I'M TRYING TO BUILD A COMPANY
THAT IS THE RIGHT FIT
FOR EVERYBODY,
SO I'M THINKING MAYBE
THIS ISN'T THE RIGHT FIT,
SO I WILL PASS.
GOOD LUCK TO YOU, LINDSEY.
Cuban:
GOOD LUCK, LINDSEY.
THANK YOU, GUYS.
Corcoran: GOOD LUCK.
I APPRECIATE IT.
I'M GLAD THAT
WE DIDN'T DO A DEAL
'CAUSE IT DIDN'T FEEL RIGHT.
SO IF I WOULD CHANGE ANYTHING,
IT WOULD BE --
I DON'T EVEN KNOW
IF I WOULD CHANGE ANYTHING
BECAUSE I BELIEVE THAT'S
THE RIGHT VALUATION.
BARBARA, I THINK THAT WAS THE
BEST ADVICE YOU'VE EVER GIVEN.
MM-HMM.
SHE'S WILDLY OPTIMISTIC.
YEP.
MM.
BUT GREAT ENTREPRENEURS
LIVE IN PARANOIA.
SHE'S JUST BLINDED
BY THE LIGHT.
♪♪